CCSD fire in a teacher at a Valley
Middle School after allegedly writing
the n-word on a school white board we
thank you for joining us on 8 news now
at six I'm Brian Loftus I'm Kirsten
Joyce School administrators quick to
take action after launching an
investigation it allegedly happened at
Silvestri Junior High that's in the
South part of town along Silverado Ranch
Boulevard near Maryland Parkway and
that's where we find our education
reporter Joshua peguero joining us now
with more details Joshua
hello Brian Kirsten the teacher was a
substitute and in video we just obtained
a few minutes ago that teacher is
captured on video using racially
insensitive language as part of a lesson
plan and less than 24 hours after that
CCSD fired him
we're told from students and a parent
that during an English class A teacher
wrote the n-word several times on a
whiteboard this is video captured by a
student of that lesson we have blurred
the racial slurs and the teachers face
there's really no excuse for this
there should not be any type of lesson
around the n-word
so it's really appalling and it's
hurtful Camila bywaters is the National
Action Network says there is a lack of
anti-racism training for staff at CCSD
and firing the sub doesn't solve the
problem but it's not enough we continue
to continuing to see this culture of
racial insensitivity we're continuing to
see this culture of violence towards
black students within our schools in an
email sent to students and parents
Silvestri principal Yvette tippetts says
I would like to inform you at the school
administration became aware of an
incident on our campus and involved
communication that contained racial
implications the principle adds in part
we will not tolerate behaviors that
contradict an inclusive community
function of Staff reporting live from
Sylvester Junior High School Joshua
peguero 8 News Now